What's happening?
Oh!
Everything's fine.
I was like, why do I hear...
I was like, what happened to the audio?
I went to the bathroom and I wasn't listening to anything.
And then I come back and it just sounds like chaos.
I turned down the audio before, but...
I'll just do that.
There we go.
It's just, what's happening?
What's happening?
Oh!
That's so funny.
I didn't realize I had my own stream open.
Wow.
Anyway, I had it open in another tab.
That's what happened in case you were like, what the heck was that?
Anyway...
There was just so much music.
I was like, what?
I've played this game for 30 minutes and it's actually as infuriating as the Ruinius game.
No way.
I was gonna say, surely it...
Really?
It's not easy?
I was like, surely it's gonna be...
It's gonna be...
Ore no Requiem Minto Experience.
Played a bit earlier and got to 95th zone.
Atlantis no Minto.
No, Phantom no Naisu.
Wait.
Oh gosh.
I didn't plan for playing so long.
I guess we'll play...
Until...
We don't.
I've been regretting her life choices.
Regretting my afterlife choices.
If you would like to play Phantom no Naisu...
The link is in the description.
This is a fan game.
A fan game by Giyoba.
I hope I said that right.
So thank you!
This music is fire.
I know!
When I was listening to it, I was like...
My original opening.
And it actually has...
Thank you, thank you!
Oh, I actually forgot to say that.
Because I got so distracted by my endless voice.
We just started the stream, so...
Welcome in!
I always want to call you Sir Steak.
That's why I like... hesitate, you know?
Thank you guys!
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
I hope you had a good...
I hope you had a good stream.
Pyrobot, thanks for the 10 gift cards!
Oh my gosh, oh my gosh, they don't stop.
We've already thanks you for the 5 gift cards.
Thank you!
You're in a video game, and I know!
But if you die in the video game...
I can't die in real life.
I'm already dead.
So, I think we're fine.
Jack, thanks for 2 months!
Thanks for the gifts.
Yay!
Well, I'm glad.
Thanks for being around to be able to get another gifted.
Oh my gosh.
It's all green!
A shadow!
Thanks!
Welcome to Bubble Show!
I missed your stream yesterday because birthday dinner.
Devlin, was it your birthday yesterday?
Daddy, thanks for the 10 gifted!
Missed, welcome back!
Call me Troy, welcome back!
Can we propose to you at the concert?
Why?
Invisible Moose, thanks for the 10 gifted!
Oh my gosh, wait, there's actually...
Which ones have I not read?
Oh my...
Say, happy birthday!
Oh gosh, wait, I'm getting...
Wait, you guys, slow down please.
I'm getting overwhelmed.
Wait...
There's too many things happening.
There's too many...
Jake, thanks for the super chat.
Okay, I have two birthday songs I need to sing.
Hold on, I am going to turn down the music just a little bit.
At least that noise.
As you can see, I've turned it down quite a bit.
I think that should be okay.
Okay, maybe it's just loud for me.
There we go.
Oh my gosh!
Thank you guys!
Okay, first, Devlin.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear Devlin.
Happy birthday!
Mint.
Mint never changes.
Sing happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear Senka Shura.
Happy birthday!
Oh my gosh, it's funny that you were the Metal Gear reference.
Okay, I have a reason for this, right?
So I got art.
Or rather, I saw my cup.
My cup designed today for Gamer Subs.
And I actually...
Part of it has a Metal Gear reference on it, right?
Because of course it does.
But I asked them to...
I asked them to make my panties transparent.
So that when you fill up the cup, it also changes the color.
So...
Yeah, they could be any color.
They could be lilac.
They could be blue.
They could be pink.
Whatever.
Whatever you desire.
Yes, yes.
Maybe it's a bad idea.
But, you know.
So...
So whenever that comes out, I hope you guys will enjoy.
If you decide to purchase.
And...
Yeah.
But it's also a Metal Gear reference too.
You'll know immediately.
But it had me thinking.
I was just like, if I were to ever get a flavor...
Like, what would it be called, you know?
And I was like, what if instead of Snake Eater, it's Snake Drinker?
It's kind of funny.
Instead of Snake Eater.
Right?
And it's legally distinct, so...
Probably.
Who's JFJ?
Oh, Snake Oil.
Oh, you're right.
It's true.
Who's JFJ?
I don't know that guy.
Never change, you freak.
Yeah, but mine is a Metal Gear reference.
Right?
It's different.
Snake Freaker?
Well, I don't...
I don't have any...
You know, right now there's no plans for...
For a flavor, so...
It was just me thinking about it.
Because I don't want to be...
If the opportunity ever arises, I don't want to be blindsided by me being like...
I need a month to think about this, you know?
So...
Finally, a goof cup to drink my goof juice.
Which I used Code Boomer to buy.
Thank you!
Yes, Code Boomer.
Oh my gosh, I checked my...
I checked my gamer stuff for the first time yesterday.
Like...
How much I receive when you use my code and everything.
And oh my gosh, you guys actually use my code!
Like, a lot!
Oh my gosh!
You guys actually use it!
I was so... I was so... I was like...
That was so much!
I was like, no way!
So, thank you guys.
Sorry, I don't want this to seem like an advertisement or anything.
I was just thinking about it right before stream, so...
And also right before stream, actually like all day today, I was...
A couple of months ago, I streamed me doing a hand cam of me putting together a...
What do you call...
It's like one of those... You guys know those bookshelf...
Like...
It's like a bookshelf holder.
But...
It's supposed to be...
Like...
A miniature world.
Kind of...
A bookend!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah!
But...
It's supposed to... Inside of it is like a miniature world and it's just like...
Cute, right?
And so I started building a little bit of that.
Robinhood!
Thank you for the tag, gifted!
Thank you!
Thank you for commissioning the art that I used for the thumbnail too.
I use it both times.
Thank you, thank you.
When are we getting a Minto cup?
I don't know when it's coming out.
To be honest.
I only saw the concept for the first time today.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We like you a little bit.
Thank you.
But...
So I streamed that some months ago and I literally have not touched it ever since.
Like, it was just sitting...
All the little tiny bits and pieces were just sitting on a little table in my room this entire time.
And so I was just like, I'm putting this together now.
Because I've been cleaning.
I've been doing some mega cleaning.
Especially because Matara is coming over.
I've been doing some mega cleaning and I've been also...
I rearranged some stuff in my room and...
Maybe, like, once I get things nice, I will maybe take a picture of my setup.
Because I'm really proud of it.
I did, like, cable management and it looks so nice and clean.
And I'm like...
It's so good.
And...
Is this the game music?
It is!
Yeah, it's from...
It's my original opening song.
But...
I was like, I'm gonna put this together before she gets here.
Not for her, but because I want...
I'm just, like, you know, getting a bunch of clutter out of the way.
And it's just been sitting on this table.
And so I spent...
I've been working on it for, like, several hours now.
My thumb is numb.
And my fingers are covered in glue and they're all red.
Because it's, like, you know, it's wood pieces that you're, like, sticking in.
And they're, like, you have to press down really hard.
And so my thumb, like, is really sore right now.
But I got a lot of progress done.
I think...
I think probably next week I can stream finishing it.
So I'll get a lot more done.
Maybe, like, tomorrow and the day after.
I have some other stuff I need to do too.
That I was supposed to do today instead.
But I said I'll do it tomorrow.
So I think I'll do that next week.
Where we finish it on stream.
And then I can put it on my bookshelf.
I can put it in between all of my doujins.
And it'll look really beautiful.
Because my doujinshi are also pink.
It'll go in so perfectly.
Yeah.
It'll fit in so perfectly.
I've been slightly pinkifying my room.
Like...
Hi Mito, it is not my birthday.
But it is the birthday of the hit game Super Smash Bros.
Melee for the Nintendo Gamecube.
It would mean the world if you could sing for them.
Happy birthday to Smash.
Happy birthday Super Smash Bros.
Melee for Nintendo Gamecube.
Happy birthday.
Smash or pass.
Melee.
I have room on my bookshelf.
I was just looking at it.
I was like, wait a second, do I have room?
I actually had to clear a shelf because it was all Metal Gear.
Now there's only just one shelf that's all Metal Gear.
Now I have an extra shelf.
Minten is saying happy birthday for any Metal Gear Solid but sang for Smash.
I sang Snake Eater.
Actually no, that's not true.
That's not true.
I sang happy birthday to Metal Gear Solid 2.
That was literally like last week.
I did.
I sang happy birthday in the off collab with Doki Bird.
I sang happy birthday to Metal Gear Solid 2.
I did.
I sang it.
She gets baited so easily when it comes to the truth.
I do.
Because the truth reigns supreme.
I just realized you guys, I forgot my drink.
I'm going to go grab it real quick.
I'm going to go grab my... I forgot my drink.
Sorry.
I told you, I was working on this model thing.
I was not ready.
I got really... I got lost in the sauce.
I was like so... I was so in it.
And then like 15 minutes before stream I was like...
So...
Yeah, I'm just going to go grab...
I got it.
It's like...
It's already made.
I made it before stream and then I forgot to grab it.
Okay.
Why am I explaining myself to you?
Was it Metal Gear Solid 3's birthday earlier this month?
It was like two days ago or something.
It was this month, yeah.
It's already made.
Why am I explaining...
BRB.
Alrighty.
Super Famicom.
Oh my goodness.
Don't scatter!
I'm right here.
Don't scatter.
What are you doing?
Sillies?
Don't scatter.
Well guys, if this is just as difficult...
I'm scared.
What if I...
I...
What if it...
What if it's so bad?
You should be scared.
Like the part where she explained why it was okay for her to leave for longer than it took to get her drink.
What are you talking about?
I have...
Every time I leave my room, I pet each cat.
Is that the explanation you wanted?
I have to check on my cats every time I leave.
I go...
And I pet them and I kiss them.
And I say...
Be good boys and girls.
Well, boy and girl.
Acceptable.
Thank you.
Wait, did you totally miss...
I like the part where she explained why it was okay for her to leave...
For longer than it took...
Huh?
I'm confused.
Can you do a few takes on the Blade Runner quote?
That's for an animation.
Okay, hold on.
Let me turn the music off.
Okay.
I have five cats.
The struggle is real.
You can't hear it, right?
Okay, yeah, you can't.
Okay.
I'll try for this animation.
This is the one with the lady in the sky, right?
Right?
I like watching the Kiara one.
Okay.
Hello, handsome.
What a day, hmm?
You look lonely.
I can fix that.
You look like a good wisp.
Is that good?
Is that okay?
I'll try one more.
One more.
Hello, handsome.
What a day, hmm?
You look lonely.
I can fix that.
You look like a good wisp.
Okay.
Stop it, you guys.
It's forced acting.
The perfect stream to bleed out in the snow too.
And I will be bleeding out in Phantom No Nazo.
Let's play!
Actually, I was just like, surely I'll be able to get through this so easily.
And then maybe after if I, you know, still wanna keep going...
I can play like Freak or Treat or something since I haven't done that.
Is that the movie with Ryan Reynolds?
Yes.
The Blade Runner?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
No.
No, no, guys.
What was Ryan Reynolds in?
Wolverine, Wolverine, Wolverine.
He's not Wolverine.
Deadpool!
Deadpool, Deadpool, Deadpool.
No, he wasn't in the notebook.
I remember.
He was in the notebook too.
At least I have to watch that.
Should I?
What is a hardcore mode?
Should I do easy?
No.
This is my own fan game.
I'm not gonna do easy mode.
Why would I even consider that?
The journey starts.
Oh.
Here I go.
Not that way.
I like how I'm poor.
Oh, 50 yen!
Oh my God.
I forgot you can't touch the guys.
I forgot that this game is not for the faint of heart.
What is this?
Oh, thank goodness.
Oh no!
Gibby, why did you do this to me?
Gibby, why did you make such a difficult game?
Oh my God!
OK, now we are safe.
OK, I'm just gonna jump over it.
One Zone!
We made it to One Zone.
My favorite one.
Why did I jump?
I thought the...
I thought the gravestone would block it.
This is too accurate.
This is too...
Oh my God.
No, please don't kill me.
Please.
Oh my God.
No, no, no, no.
How...Gibby, how many times did you play Phantom No Nazo to truly understand its intricacies?
You're even getting the jumping part correct.
Like it's actually terrifying how accurate this feels.
OK, I'm gonna make a...I'm gonna risk it all for the biscuit all.
Risking it!
Risking is good business!
You must take high risks, high rewards!
Yeah, baby!
Oh my God.
No, no, no.
No.
Oh, thank goodness.
All I did was walk!
And then...
OK.
Risk it all!
Oh my gosh, sorry.
I did not mean to scream like that.
Oh gosh.
No!
There's a hundred stages, you guys!
There's one hundred stages!
I love Mint's generational throws.
What do you mean by that?
Like I'm making fun of old people or...
Throwing shade at the elderly?
Bozo?
Yeah.
Let's pass this one.
Oh my God, guys.
Wait.
No!
Oh no, it was a trap!
No, no, please!
I can still make it.
This is how you do it, guys.
So is this like a reskin of Atlantis No Nazo or is it a full new game?
Full new game, I believe.
Risk it all!
You have an attack.
Oh you're right!
I do have an attack!
You're right!
Completely...
Forgot.
Wait, can I attack?
Can I kill these guys?
Can I kill the Wisps?
She hurts us!
Oh, OK.
OK.
Oh my God!
Please, please, please, please.
Leave me alone.
No!
I think what was really funny about this was seeing the comments...
Oh my God, how did I make that?
Seeing the comments on this, on the Itch.io page from this was really funny because there was someone who was just like...
I don't know anything about Mint Phantom, but I'm a big fan of Atlantis No Nazo.
Can even I play this game?
Please.
No, please.
I need to...
No, no, no.
OK.
Close, close.
No, no, no.
I think they were worried that they wouldn't be able to understand some of the attacks and stuff if they were like...
You know, centered around me kind of deal.
Like, oh, I don't know Mint Phantom, so I don't know how she...
Why you would use this attack unless you watch her...
Please.
Oh my gosh.
How do I... How do I open the doors again?
How do I open the doors again?
Bomb.
Wait, I don't have... Oh wait, do I have to throw it myself?
Attack it.
I have to get down there first I think.
Alright.
Oh gosh, I'm running out of time.
Ten Question Minky Quiz.
I did it!
It's so cruel.
Goodbye cruel world.
Gosh, I'm having such major...
I'm having so many flashbacks to this.
I feel like I'm in... I can't even speak.
I never want to hear you guys say she hates us again.
Not when this is how I'm being treated.
By my own wisps.
Oh my God.
Please.
So if I crouch and throw.
Oh OK.
OK.
No, no, no.
Please let me down soon.
Third zone!
Oh gosh.
Anything up here?
Maybe not.
I got money though.
Yeah.
Oh my God his body parts.
Oh my God.
Double, double.
Double trouble.
There are body parts everywhere.
It's really gross.
Awesome.
Oh my God.
I'm never going to make it back here.
I'm going to lose all my lives and I'll never be able to come back.
Oh my God.
Please, please, please.
Where are the wisps?
OK.
Throw.
Oh my God.
OK.
We are gaming.
Nice, nice.
Oh gosh.
Throw, throw, throw!
No!
No, not close enough.
Very gently.
Gently now.
OK.
Ninth zone!
Well that
was unfair.
Welcome to the world of X-No-Nazo.
Welcome to the world... What is hardcore?
No!
There is no way anyone can do this.
Oh my God.
I did it on purpose.
You know?
Because...
I did it on purpose, you know?
So that we could...
So that we could just continue on normally, you know?
Are you going to leave or...
Oh wait.
I don't need to touch you guys.
Hey come here.
Fall to your death.
Yeah, that's right.
Oh, that's right.
There is nothing here.
Not that I know of at least.
Maybe I need to explode something over there.
Maybe...
I should have done that instead of going to this hellhole.
Please.
I don't want to be back here.
Hidden door?
Yeah, I think there might be a hidden door over there.
Oh God, please.
No!
There we go.
No, just kidding.
Please.
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes.
Oh my God.
I have to be careful.
Be careful!
Don't get greedy.
Yes!
Okay.
Third zone!
Look, there is a door there.
I'm just going to jump over this guy.
Oh no!
No!
My God!
There is a manual in the menu.
It explains Hardcore.
I thought Hardcore was just one life.
Is it different than that?
More than just one single life?
You know what?
Maybe it's safer to just blow these guys up.
We're in no rush.
Good thing I blowed him up.
Good thing I blowed him up though.
Good thing.
Okay, keep going.
Keep blowing up.
Oh, come on.
There we go.
Blow it up.
Nice.
Okay.
I think I need to run immediately.
Okay, I need to like...this one I need to go immediately.
Okay, here we go.
Where are they?
There they are.
Where did they come from?
Oh no, no, no, no, no!
There we go, there we go.
What the...
Why were there doubles?
I flew!
Why is this game so accurate?
Why is it so accurate?
No!
God, why?
You studied the game too hard, Gibby.
Please!
I don't care!
We are going to the 8th zone!
No way, I want to go back.
I want to go back!
Okay, let's continue onward.
Okay.
Retreat!
Tactical retreat!
We
got it!
We got it!
Why is it a different color?
Oh my gosh!
I got used to the car...
Oh my God!
It requires...
It requires every...
Every ounce of...
Oh my God!
Please!
The precision!
I'm running in traffic!
Why do I need the money anyway?
Okay, you can't go the other way!
I like the music in this one.
America, the cornfields!
I love the cornfields of America!
You guys, I'm going to lose it here at the 10th zone!
Kachominto-san!
Why is this suddenly Game Center CX?
No!
I don't want to be on it!
Please!
Whose existence is suffering?
What's your order at Whack Donald's, you guys?
I can't look at chat in this area, you guys.
I gotta full pay attention.
We did it!
A big whack.
No!
Please God, no!
I'm still in the streets!
I think this game is harder than the original.
Is Henya driving those trucks?
Oh my God.
I was in tears at the clip that Zentraia posted of Henya driving.
20 piece chimpkin wick nuggets.
Sorry.
It's all over.
There has to be more secret doors, right?
I believe.
Wait, give me my money.
There was money over here, wasn't there?
Wasn't there?
Am I crazy?
Wasn't there a platform up there?
I guess not.
Oh!
Reaction time of a... of a... of a bunny.
OK, let's try.
It was a different stage?
Ah, I see.
I knew it!
Oh my God.
Oh my gosh!
I know Atlantis, I know Nazo too much now, actually.
That's actually concerning.
Wait a second.
Oh my God, where are we anyway?
Wait, this is the sec... second...
Oh!
Please!
Yes!
If we go... If we drop...
If we drop down... Oh my gosh.
No, it's fine.
8th zone?
Wait, wasn't this the bad zone?
Yes!
Oh my Go...
I wonder if we can get downstairs down there.
Oh shit!
What?
What is this hitbox?
I swear!
Don't come towards me!
You freak!
Not affectionate.
There we go.
I wonder if there is a way to get down there.
You think?
If I like drop down and quickly...
This game also has like... This game is actually a little different than Atlantis on Nazo because...
Oh!
If I went for the other way!
I should have got dropped from the left.
OK, we'll do it from the left.
I forgot how far you drop from, you know.
But there is also different outfits in this.
There is different outfits and different power-ups.
Which makes it different from Atlantis on Nazo.
A little bit.
OK, let's drop from here!
Nevermind.
It's too accurate to the original man!
It's so...
I say well made like lovingly, you know.
Like it's well made and it's a great parody, you know.
It's a great recreation of the original.
Truly.
It's very accurate.
Oh my gosh.
Give me my Oshibari.
Oh it's a decoy octopus.
Welcome to the membership.
Ah decoy octopus.
Oh my gosh.
Like here is there...
Is there a door here?
It looks suspicious, right?
See?
You guys, I know.
I think with the Atlantis on Nazo brain at this point.
I'm a...
What is this?
Wait, what is this?
I think with the actual Atlantis on Nazo brain.
I can't believe this.
I'm becoming a...
Oh no, no, no.
Ah no, no, no.
OK, we might have to like... Hold on.
Let's prepare...
No, no.
I don't want to prepare the door just yet.
OK, here we go.
Nice, nice.
Oh no.
Nice!
No!
How can I mess up the last one?
OK, hold on.
Not nice.
Honestly, I got lucky those past couple times.
Let's reset the timer.
Grab more... Oh, this money I already stole from that wallet.
Need a notebook strategy guide.
I think someone... I think...
I think I saw that someone had streamed this.
Actually, I think it's easier going from this side.
Nice.
OK.
Ah!
Shit.
I pressed... I pressed it, but sometimes...
OK, hold on.
I want more time.
I want more time!
Looking forward to reading your Phantom Nonazo guide on GameFAQs.
This is the strat, you guys.
This is how you get more time, you know.
I need to know what this is.
Is it money?
Is it a power-up?
Like, if it's a power-up, that's huge.
We gotta have a power-up.
Oh, is the block upstairs?
Presenting... Preventing me, not presenting me.
I'm sorry.
See, I have to do a small jump like that, you know.
Guys, we'll get this.
We'll get this thing.
Ah!
Oh my gosh!
No!
Anime is so bad!
At least we are not in the streets, you guys.
Honestly.
This is pretty tame.
It's the same attack.
Extra life?
I just have a coin!
I don't know what it means, but...
I don't know what it means.
Is it just a collectible?
Wait, do I have to go to the...
Do I have to go to that...
You got glide.
Oh my gosh!
That's huge!
Wait, that's actually so huge for the next one?
That's actually so...
Oh my god!
That's huge for this next world!
What the...
Are you OK?
This one.
Oh wait, I can float to the bottom part.
I was thinking this.
I can't...
Oh you can't...
OK,
so you can glide.
OK, I'm too much of a baby.
Alright, they can glide.
So
from here...
I'm scared.
We made it!
Do
we go down?
75th zone!
This is evil.
I killed a zombie!
Zombie!
I killed another zombie.
Oh my god, I killed another zombie.
Sorry for flashing lights everybody.
Flashing light.
Are we gonna run out of time?
Oh no, it's over here!
76th zone!
I slowly sunk to my death.
Oh I have to go up.
OK, I have to keep going up.
And around.
Wait for that bat to pass.
OK.
And then...
Wait, this is gonna be tricky.
This is gonna be tricky.
Oh gosh.
How do I jump up there though?
No, no.
We don't have a lot of time left.
Oh shoot!
Oh gosh!
Please, please register my input.
I threw that out of...
You think there has to be a secret door?
I think you're just supposed to be fast here, right?
I don't even know where a secret door would be at.
I think you just have to be fast.
Oh
no, there we go.
Oh my gosh, I almost just kept running and not even thinking.
I was just like, what if I just hold right?
Hold right in this world.
We all just move to the right and then we move to the left and we never think about...
No, no!
Oh gosh!
I think I can stand with these guys, yeah.
Shoot.
I think as soon as...
I can't read it.
I'm sorry.
I'm on a time limit.
It's too tight.
What if I just always hold left?
What if I just hold left forever?
I don't consider any holes.
I don't consider anything.
I just hold left.
Hold left.
Wait, do I not...
Oh, sorry.
Wait, I was gonna say, do I not have my ghost anymore?
I don't think I have my ghost jump anymore.
Oh, these are...oh wait, I saw ashes.
I thought...oh.
I love Ryan Reynolds in that movie.
No, I'm not sick.
I got something caught in my throat.
My ghost medal disappeared.
No!
I was relying on it.
I'm gonna run out of time here.
Oh my gosh!
What's the timing here?
The timing was good.
Yeah, I just...I don't think I'm gonna make it, guys.
Good run.
Yeah!
How did we get there again?
I discovered...
I discovered a...oh my god, please come this way.
Yes, thank you.
Where was it though?
The grave.
But rather there was first here, right?
There...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
OK, from here.
OK, yeah, yeah, yeah.
This is good.
From here?
And then we go collect the coin?
Then we go collect the coin?
Take.
Feel my fury.
And then here?
Sixth!
Coin.
Oh my gosh.
I'm regressing.
There we go.
First try!
It just takes me a bit to get into the groove of the Atlantis No Nazo...
universe, you know?
The...
A-N-N extended universe.
Die zombie.
Oh my god.
I'm starting to believe.
I don't know about that.
That's a little...
I
glided right into his face!
Messed up.
Messed up!
I told you.
Believing was maybe a bit too strong of a word.
How did I do it before?
I think I just did like a...
Oh gosh.
Oh god, I'm scared.
Okay, I have to double.
Wait, if I fall...
Does it count?
Okay.
Okay, so I have to...
Tiny, tiny jumping!
I did it!
Nice!
Okay.
Goodness, because we were almost out of...
We were almost out of time.
Have confidence.
No confidence a moment.
Okay, then we have this annoying place.
Explode zombie.
Oh my gosh.
Too close a zombie.
Gosh.
Okay, we are back here.
We are back to the bats.
Alright, this is the furthest... This is as far as we have gotten.
In this game.
This is the furthest we have gotten you guys.
Okay.
The music sounds so sad.
That's just how I sound.
Or how I feel.
I just feel...
Worst part is...
At least with Atlantis, there was a guide I could look up, you know?
I don't think I can jump over this guy.
So close!
I don't think I can jump over him though.
Secret door in top left.
I tried throwing a bomb at there.
I don't want to waste the time to do it.
I don't have the coin anymore.
I can't jump and hover everybody.
I tried it last time we were in here.
The coin disappears after you fall.
Two.
Oh there.
There is ashes.
Try different timing.
It's harder than you think.
Because I'm trying to go as soon as the bat is gone from me.
Since the bat flies beyond me, I can't...
I can't go before...
Oh my god!
I need to...
And also, I swear, I think the timing is different from the left.
Like when you start over from the very left.
I think it changes the timing of it.
I kind of remember how there were the ghosts that did that trail.
And then if I went over, it would reset the timing.
I think that's what's happening here.
Oh...
Okay, so I have to... Ouch, I just bit my tongue again.
I have to be... I have to be...
Okay, I know I have to have the second block...
I have to have the block in my view.
I have to have this block in my view for the bats to not be weird.
If I go over too far, it doesn't work.
At least I didn't die, but we are going to run out of time!
Okay, so I can block it in view.
No!
Shooting the bats mid-air.
Let's try that.
Yeah, let's try killing the bats.
Let's try killing the bats.
Because you can!
Well, hold on.
Hold on.
This is possible.
It's possible.
Maybe.
No.
There we go.
Alright.
You sound like the Joker.
All we have to do is kill the Batman.
That was close.
That was too close for comfort.
Wait.
I need to go up.
I need to go up here.
I don't even know.
You guys, we might be going towards a totally...
We might be going down the most difficult path and we don't even realize it.
Oh, I'm scared.
First try.
Watch it go 76 to 3 or something.
Even if it does...
Honestly, Atlantis no Nazo is such a mystery.
The numbers just don't really count, I think.
It's just... It's just a mystery.
Honestly, it doesn't even matter what the order is as long as you make it to 100.
But what horrors does level 100 have in this game?
Level 100, you have to have invincibility in the original.
So I'm scared.
I'm scared!
Zombie.
That's a zombie!
Die zombie!
Die zombie.
Oh gosh.
OK, we are back everybody.
We are back with a full set of lives.
So maybe we can make it.
Minky power!
OK, I have to have this one in sight and...
This one in sight and...
Oh shit!
No!
The timing on that...
At least it wasn't a fall.
Mervy!
I blame you!
I wonder how you get... I wonder how you get the skins.
See, you have Minto.
You have a Chilly.
You have Space.
You have a Mermaid.
You have Hotdog.
You have Otaku.
You have Idol.
You have Snow.
You have a Bunny.
You have a Jiangshi.
You have Mummy.
You have a Solid.
You have a Nude.
You have a Lilac.
Oh my gosh!
Wait!
Mid 3.0!
Oh my gosh!
Wait!
We have Turquoise too!
30% more ear.
50% less eye.
OK, we'll do that one.
We have more ear.
Punished Minto.
That was close I think.
No!
I knew it.
When I went for it I was like wait, I'm not close enough to the edge.
I'm not close enough to the edge.
See how fast that second bat was?
How do we go in with a full set of lives?
OK
Oh shoot!
How is that cheating?
What are you talking about?
This is how you play the game!
What?
Cheating?
My butt!
This is how you play the game!
OK
At least it's not very hard to get back here.
I just want to make it through!
What in the parkour ship is this place?
I want to be a parkour master!
Oh gosh!
Once again, I'm exploiting the game's mechanics.
I'm exploiting the game's mechanics.
AKA cheating.
You guys have never played Atlantis No Nazo and it clearly shows right now.
Your gaming inexperience is really coming to full light right now you guys.
It's a little embarrassing.
Maybe play some big boy games and then come back to me, OK?
Oh shoot!
If at first you don't succeed, try, try again.
Albert Einstein.
Please, don't get me!
Oh my god, that was close.
The random pattern on the birds is bullshit.
I know!
It's so rude!
I wish I had the glide here.
I can't believe you lose the power-ups.
My
tippy toes!
My tippy toes were touching the tip!
My tippy toes were just right on the block, man!
Sometimes I hate my controller.
I don't know if it's me.
I mean sure, blame me.
But I am pressing the button.
I am pressing the button.
I am pressing jump.
I promise you!
And I'm holding it down!
I'm holding it down!
No!
How old were you when it came out, Atlantis Nozzle Master?
What are you talking about?
I still beat it.
Try jumping over.
You can't!
There is no time.
There is no time to jump over the bats.
At least the first one.
You might be able to jump over the second ones.
Money.
Oh wait, not this way.
I wonder though.
I wonder!
Maybe here?
Maybe down there?
No, maybe here?
Maybe here?
How do I make it so it doesn't...there we go.
Nothing really!
Okay.
I thought...
You thought...
Where is the try?
Actually...
Am I stuck in a loop?
Come on!
What's over here?
What's on the other side?
What if I just...LEAP OF FAITH!
Everybody, I tested it for you.
I know you were all so curious.
There is nothing...oh wait, I'm in the 1th zone.
Oh my God!
Get me out of here please!
Oh no!
No, no, no!
Please get me out of here!
Please, please, please, please!
I don't want to be here!
No, no, no!
Please!
Oh God!
I did it again!
No, no, no!
Please!
They are coming for me!
Oh my God!
Please!
They are coming for me!
And...go.
Okay, there we go.
Alrighty.
The 1th zone.
The 2th zone.
BabyCorn, thanks for the gift!
Thank you!
The 1st zone.
The 2th zone.
Why?
Where is the bone zone?
Give us what we want!
Give the people what they want!
Send us to the bone zone!
A fan made this?
Yeah!
It's so good!
In like a horrible way.
Like it's so accurate.
We hate that.
I was like, surely this will be...oh my God.
It will be so...you know.
Not easy, but like...
Nobody wants to play Atlantis No Nazo.
Nobody...
Nobody wants to play Atlantis No Nazo for real.
This is just going to make you...
Every time...you guys are just going to get mad at me.
You guys are just going to be like...God.
Actually he made another game too.
Gibby.
Sorry, I call you Gibby.
But...
But...and it's so good actually.
I kind of...I was like...I kind of want to...
If I hadn't just...
You know, if I hadn't just gotten this new BGM for my intro...
I feel like I would have used it instead.
It's so good.
Mistyping of the dead.
Yeah!
This game reminds me of McKids on NES.
McKids.
What are the McKids McPlaying?
Why are they playing Atlantis No Nazo?
Toughest game ever.
Can you leave?
Thank you.
Oh my God!
On his head!
Cute.
Yarn for the Nazo.
You know what guys?
Oh my gosh.
I am going to try...
Not dying here.
There we go.
I'm going to try...
The 8th level.
Over here.
But with the glide.
It might be fine if we have the glide.
You know?
Oh.
I lost it.
I was double pressing and I was like why is it not working?
You didn't realize?
I thought it was user error.
I'll be honest.
Oh my God!
Wait!
It's not that they are invisible.
They just aren't there!
It's not that the blocks aren't visible.
They just disappear!
Oh no.
This is...no.
There is no way.
What's the point?
See?
They just aren't there!
That's craziness!
Oh my God!
I thought they were invisible blocks.
I thought this would be doable.
Only 15?
I was just curious.
We are not actually going to play on easy mode you guys.
I was just...
Wait.
I was just curious.
Like how many lives...like what's the difference between easy mode, you know?
That's all.
I wasn't actually going to do it.
I don't play easy mode.
That would be stupid.
I wish this game had save states.
If anything.
Give me a checkpoint please.
Maybe we go back to the streets.
I'm sick of the birds.
I believe in us.
We can handle the streets.
We can handle ourselves.
We are not a kid anymore.
How did we get to the streets?
How did we get to the American...
How did we get to McDonald's?
Is it this way?
How did we get there?
He's losing it.
He's losing it!
It wasn't...
Through the wisp zone.
Okay, never mind.
You know what?
I love...
I love the birds.
Excuse me zombie.
I'm a bit of a time limit.
Thank you.
I
think one of the hardest parts about this game is remembering when I have to do a short jump and when to do a long jump.
Like the different types of jumps.
It feels like Jump King in that regard.
Oh my god.
I saw someone do a speedrun of the Not Jump King in Holocure.
And I think I'm just gonna follow them.
Nice.
I'm a baseball player.
I think I'm just gonna see what they do for their...
For their things.
Their jump strengths, you know.
Wait, you saw a 3 minute one?
I saw...
I saw one that was 5 minutes.
Please, please, please.
Okay, good.
And down we go.
Wait, when do I lose the ghost?
When do I lose the jump ability?
Or the glide ability?
Because I still have it.
I thought it was when I fell down the hole.
Looks like after 3 deaths.
Only when you fall into a pit.
Then maybe I'll be okay here.
What?
There's a 3 minute task run.
Oh, task runs are no fun.
Eating Mike Tyson's ass!
Thank you for the 5, Captain!
Oh, I do still have it.
Concentration.
Concentration, everybody.
The
birds.
Wait, these aren't birds.
They're bats.
I've been calling them birds this whole time.
They're not even birds.
Okay, next one.
There we go.
Okay, so jump over them?
I'm too scared.
Okay, I have the timing though.
It's just this first one.
Shoot.
Okay, hold on.
Wrong.
There we go.
Too far.
I think gliding will definitely kill me here.
I think.
No way!
Oh my God.
Messed up.
There was never two of them standing right next to each other before.
Screw it.
Sorry, I'm resetting.
I'm resetting!
Doesn't feel like a Kusoge so far.
Nah, not at all.
Of course it wouldn't feel like a Kusoge.
I'm in it.
Nothing that I'm in is a Kusoge.
Oh my God!
I can't make this heckin' jump!
Parkour is truly...
If this was Minecraft Parkour...
I'd be able to double jump.
I'd be able to... I'd be able to do everything.
Shoot!
I'd be able to jump 360.
If this was...
If this was Minecraft.
Tellin' ya.
Always jump for the beef.
I'm so sad.
I saw people say that they got that.
That they jump for the beef.
What the?
Oh my gosh.
No.
Please.
On their thing.
But mine didn't... I watched Parkour 7 and mine didn't have it.
At least I didn't die.
I'm gonna run out of time.
Yeah, I have float, but...
Oh gosh.
I feel I'm gonna hear this song in my sleep.
Next one.
And once you glide, you can't stop gliding.
I think that's...
Like there's no... I think I can't use glide here, because once I glide...
I will just go past the block.
Well, I lost my glide.
You know what?
I don't even want it!
I don't even want the glide!
I don't need it!
I don't need you!
I don't love you!
I don't want you in my life!
I definitely thought that said glide is for rabies instead of glide is for babies.
Why does the timing change?
I miss glide.
I miss having the option.
Even if I never use it, I at least have the option.
I miss having options.
Can't help but feel guilty with how much your suffering makes me laugh.
Sorry, Minky.
That's OK.
That's why I do these things.
It's like a little bit of schadenfreude that you feel.
Dummy VTuber.
She tries so hard and always fails.
I hope she fails more.
You know what?
It's so funny when VTubers fail, because I am a winner.
And her failure means I'm winning.
Look at her.
She screams at the screen.
Dummy VTuber.
Dummy VTuber, don't you know that it's a skill issue?
Why do you yell so loud when it's your fault?
Oh gosh.
I'll never play this game and I'll never be able to know how good or bad I am at this game.
But I know that I'm the greatest and I would be able to beat Dummy VTuber in anything.
Dummy VTuber.
She started with 15 lives.
Only 4 lives left.
Why does she keep trying?
You know what?
I like when she falls and dies and screams.
It really gives my life meaning.
Die again, Dummy VTuber.
Die again.
I want to see her suffering.
I want to see her suffering and all the hope drain from your eyes.
Look at her.
She screamed again.
Dummy VTuber.
She did exactly what I wanted.
She died for my entertainment.
VTuber fell down the hole.
I clapped.
Single cell organism.
That's what a VTuber is.
They have no brain cell to work upon.
Doesn't the Dummy VTuber know that she has to change her habits for something new to happen?
Instead, Dummy VTuber does the same thing over and over again.
That's why Dummy VTuber dies.
Oh, Dummy VTuber.
You simple being.
I love watching a single cell organism try to be sentient.
Isn't it just so funny?
Try, try as you might, Dummy VTuber, but you'll never make it.
One HP in a dream.
Try dumping...jumping.
Dumping?
I
didn't mean to say that.
Dump o'clock.
You guys, if I get past this next room, can we call it?
Can we call that I beat the game?
Oh, I didn't...
No,
everybody who said no was too slow.
Everybody who said no, we are way too slow.
Everybody said yes first.
Yes was the first answer I saw.
You guys are too slow.
You have more experience in X-No-Nazo games than me.
So try dumping, might be the way.
Minto, are you okay?
Are you okay, Minto?
Are you okay?
Dumpy VTuber.
Oh my gosh!
I didn't see that guy.
He blended in with the wall.
Alright.
Steal the money.
Definitely dumpy.
I saw it in the Phantography tag.
I know!
My hashtag has been getting...it's been difficult to retweet stuff.
Because I'm like, but it's in my hashtag.
So, like, do I retweet it?
But it's like, it's getting very racy up in there.
And I'm like...
But this should be, maybe, I do have an 80 plus tag, you guys!
People are not using it.
If it were Snake, he'd just get a mouthful of these bats and say, disgusting.
It's so true.
Just rolled through a toll booth with my speakers blasting your Monster Mash cover.
Oh wait, I saw that ashes just now.
What do you mean?
He's green, but his shirt is purple.
I don't look at people's faces.
I'm too small.
And I don't give them the satisfaction of looking up at them.
If I'm small, I'm not giving you the satisfaction of looking up at your face.
That hurts my neck.
So I'm just used to looking down at people.
Earth coin!
Thank you so much for the 10 gifted!
I got it, right?
Wait...
Nice.
Safe.
Here we go!
So we draw a butt.
I'll be honest, of course there's gonna be some things I retweet, but for the most part, if it gets too bad, I'll just like it to show that I saw it.
I won't retweet it.
Because, you know...
Some people check Twitter, aka me, I check Twitter in public and stuff.
Or if you check it at work and all.
I at least try to like everything.
When I get around to it.
Alright.
Dummy VTuber, back out again in the dummy room.
There we go.
This is why you don't give me the glide option, everybody.
Wait, I can't check.
I want a time limit!
The timing is too tight!
You've been hit by, you've been hit by, not a brick, a bat.
You've been hit by a bat.
I'm too scared, gosh.
Ah shoot.
Oh
the misery.
Every bat is my enemy.
Oh
the misery.
Every bat is my...my enemy!
I was right there!
My hitbox is like 2 pixels.
Let me out of this room.
That was crazy.
Why did they put me in a room full of bats?
The bats made me crazy!
Sorry, I was actually...you can blame Ducky for that.
I was reading your donut.
The hitbox contains the Ahoge.
But it's invisible?
I wonder if my neighbors can ever hear me.
I got new neighbors recently.
I'm like, did the old ones move out because just randomly they would hear me screaming and crying.
They're like, this place is really haunted.
What?
This is super dead.
I feel like we hear the wails of a ghost.
It moans.
Pixel Minto will have PTSD.
Thank you for the pink zype!
I can't get the timing anymore!
I had it!
At the edge of the world.
See?
I have to wait.
Wait.
The second guy comes too fast.
Oh my god, that was so close.
Just a little...
This really makes it...
It just really...
Really solidifies it.
Gibby, is this what you wanted?
Of all fangames...
Are you a sadist?
Why?
Why this?
Why Atlantis don't nozzle?
Why?
What?
The game was updated less than 10 minutes ago.
What are you talking about?
Why?
What did they do?
What did they add?
Did they add a Minto mod?
It's all bats now.
Oh my god, that would be incredible.
Can you imagine?
OK, reset, reset.
Reset, reset.
Wait, I want to see what the update is.
Hold on, let me get the link.
It would be incredible if it was all bats.
Where does it say?
Oh, 8 minutes ago.
69 lives!
Invincible to enemies, but you cannot pick up skins.
Which I have two...
It's called explorer mode though.
It's not called Minto mode everybody.
It's because I'm an explorer.
I'm a lover.
And a licker.
That's how my mom describes my dog.
And I think my dog was a little adventurer.
Sing us a song, little batman.
Dog.
Thank you, thank you.
Choo.
Honk mimimi honk choo.
Oh my gosh, I can't even make the jump though.
I feel like the timing to jump over the bats is scarier than jumping...
between them.
I don't know.
Bus mirror Fuji.
Must be nice.
I wish...actually there is a Fuji world.
It's in the thumbnail.
I wish I could go to that world.
I wish to go to there.
I wish to go to that Fuji world.
Fuji world.
I wish to go to there.
Oh god.
This music just sounds so sad.
Game over.
New version out.
Oh wait.
You know what guys?
I've paid my dues.
You know?
I have.
I've paid my dues.
I've...
I've played...honestly...what am I thinking of playing this again?
I've paid...I also...I did everything...
I do want to show you though.
I do want to show you Giova's other game though.
Give me a second.
Let me pull it out.
Because I'm going to play it in the browser.
One second.
There we go.
I like how...oh my gosh.
It even matches my gaming background right now.
Reese, thank you for the super chat.
Hey Minto, you did great.
Can't wait for you to beat it one day.
I promise...no, hold on.
Let me rephrase this.
I...I...I want to go back to the bathroom.
I just want a break.
And I one day want to beat it.
Maybe not on stream.
I'm tired today.
I've been having crazy dreams.
The dream I had last night was like...oh my god.
It was weird.
I was like...I was basically playing...I was Phoenix Wright.
And...there was a guy who was like being framed for something.
And I was having to come to his defense and I was like, I don't know anything.
I'm not a lawyer.
And he's just like, Minto I can only count on you because everybody has painted me out to be this real bad guy.
And he was just like, I only became what they thought that I was.
If they thought I was this, so I became that.
And I was just like, I don't know buddy, maybe you...I don't know...but what's your alibi?
And he's just like, I can't tell you.
I'm like...
Made it through all five stages of grief.
Look, a fan game made for the streamer Mint Phantom.
That's me.
Inspired by her lack of auto-correct.
But you guys, the song is actually...this is so funny too.
The developer is not endorsed or affiliated with Mint Phantom, Minto Corp, or any of its talents.
Mint, Chili, Lilac, etc.
All Phantom Productions talents are 2020 Minto Corp.
It's so silly.
Yeah, the song in this is so good.
Like Gibby, did you make this song?
Did you remix it yourself?
I kind of want to switch my...my...my...what's it called?
My screen, my loading music with it.
I'm going to turn it down a bit, and then we can adjust.
So, run game.
Oh my gosh, Kodoa, I was just talking about Phoenix Wright.
I don't hear anything.
Let's do medium.
It's my...it's my...it's my typing.
How...how...how...you know medium is normal mode, right?
Hey!
Auto...oh no!
Shit!
Oh no!
Wait!
Why did I ever say this?
Orca!
Oh, we changed...
Polycure and Licky!
Say all
this!
Why?
Donkey!
Oh, Egg.
Why did I say this?
Socks yourself!
Isn't this the best song remix ever?
It's so good.
This is my favorite part of it.
We're doing awesome guys!
I'm good at this game!
We're good at this game!
Shut up!
See, this I can do.
Is this like regressing my...my typing ability, you know?
Like, because...Oh my God, Deer Stage!
What was I saying in these?
Like, what am I trying to say?
I don't even know.
Ogla.
I wonder if there's an ending.
I'll have a...
Ok, that's Mourning.
Oh, like Owl?
Ok.
I don't know what that is.
I actually just...just think...Oh my God!
Oh
my God, it's the boss!
So I send up typing letters that will be in the future and I also don't go back and correct
a mistake.
I feel so free without auto-correct.
I'm never going back!
It's impressive that my accuracy was 91%.
I can do it!
I wonder what hard mode is.
There's insane mode.
Also...
I love this.
You can have the instrumental.
Wait, is it just my normal song?
Oh, it's the same?
I think they're just faster.
Oh God!
It's hard!
Sucks yourself!
No!
I love this...what's it called?
Like...I'm gonna die!
Anime Operator, it's your birthday tomorrow!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday Anime Operator!
Happy birthday!
I love the backgrounds too.
Oh my gosh, Gibi, you did such a great job with this one.
I'm obsessed with the remix though.
I was saying when it's just the instrumental it's like...
Oh my gosh, what are they called?
The...
For some reason my brain keeps saying speedrun, but that's not it.
You know when they just pitch...
Nightcore!
Yes, Nightcore!
Thank you.
The Nightcore version.
No, but the lyrics are so good.
You need to use that as your intro.
It's so good, right?
I'm trying to figure out, because I really love what I have now.
And obviously this is based on that.
Or like it uses that song.
But I don't want, you know... I got Mitsukiyo, you guys.
Oh, it's so good though, this version.
I just went here, let's just listen to it.
Soju!
How did you find me saying all these things?
Also, are you turning the...
Oh no, Dan.
I'm gonna cry.
Are you turning the...
The sex shop here...
Into a minto shop.
Why Walt Disney?
You don't even know who Ocelot is.
That's too good.
Oh, there's the Mr. Donuts too!
This is such a nice walk of Akiba, it's so good.
I like that it ends at...
At Deer Stage.
I'm so obsessed with this fog.
I've always wanted a...
A...
Like an otomad of me.
So I'm so happy.
Why is shit up in here though?
I'm so embarrassed about that.
I'm so obsessed.
One more time!
There we go.
This is different.
I'm way slower this time.
Yeah!
So good.
She hates those!
Maple, thank you for this...
7 months?
I almost said 9 months.
Thank you!
Oh my gosh, that reminds me.
I have to get little...
I have to get new things.
We're gonna be at 1 year before we know it.
Oh wait.
I was thinking in 3 more months.
No, there's 12 months.
Nevermind.
Oh wait, there's some people that are above 7 months.
Oh no, I have to give one for a year.
The member badges.
Yeah, the member badges.
The cadence of Kojumbo does it again.
It's amazing.
I'm so happy to have this Otome.
Thank you.
So good.
Slave Monster, no!
Maple Wolfie, thank you for the superchat.
Oh my gosh.
No, oh no.
I
can make one right now.
You know what?
I'm gonna make one right...
for one year.
For one year you get...
One moment please.
One moment.
You get my chat.
It scared the hell out of me.
Oh my god.
It scared me so bad.
Let's see.
Okay, hold on.
I'm fixing the thing.
Nice stats.
I don't even look.
I just have it open for chat.
It's usually covered by whatever I'm playing.
Right now it's covered by...
Oh wait, hold on.
Nope, not settings.
Covered by Microsoft Paint.
Alright.
Oh, nope.
That's the entire screen.
Okay, hold on.
Alright.
Alright guys.
Alright guys, let's make a one year...
One year badge.
What should it be?
What should the one year badge be?
Hello there.
Hello!
Made them so strong.
This idea suck.
What do you mean a wisp?
Oh, I was going to say...
It's a wisp right now, but no, it's a little Ghostbusters thing.
Let's see.
Paintbrush?
Large size.
Actually, we need larger size.
The largest you got, ma'am.
Why is my mouse lagging?
You see this?
This one?
Oh, it stops going after a while.
Wait, this one.
Okay.
I'm going to make it a badge.
A badge of honor.
Wow, that's a really good circle.
Okay, I have to do it again though, because I have to make it darker.
Stay in the lines, Minto.
Stay in the lines.
Nice.
Oh here, I'm going to put on some BGM.
Putting on some BGM.
Got to work setting out.
Thank you Mike!
Oh, so loud on this one.
There we go.
Okay, okay.
I got to make it even darker, so you can see it, you know?
Now, this is temporary.
I'll get real ones made...
Eventually.
Don't worry about it.
I'll get real ones made eventually.
Okay, I'm just going to keep going around.
It kind of looks like a beard.
Okay.
Oh, sorry.
I didn't realize it was still spraying.
Okay, so that's the badge.
That's the badge.
And that is going to say...
One...
I guess I can only just say one.
I was going to write one here, but I think just one is good.
Like, it could be... I'm number one what?
You know?
Give a grab, welcome to membership.
Thank you!
One.
And...
What else?
Number.
Number one year.
If one, why two?
No, this is one year.
One year.
And then I'm going to draw a picture of me giving a thumbs up.
Right?
Really big thumbs up.
Like that.
Okay, now how do I... Okay.
Ears.
And hair.
But I'm going to be a wisp body because I can't draw anything else.
And...
Here's your tombstone.
Oh, it's a thumbs up.
Here, I'll put a thumbnail on it.
Oh, sorry, not a thumbnail.
Wait.
Yeah, thumbnail.
I was thinking of a toenail.
Yeah, there you go.
See?
It's my thumbnail.
It's a big old thumbs up for being number one here.
And...
Let's see.
Dead stands... It's not dead.
It stands for...
Doing every almost deed, including being number one here.
I think I have to make it smaller for YouTube to like it.
Okay, now I save.
One year.
Alright, let's see.
Thumbs up for one year dead!
This is just like one of my Japanese animes.
Alright, now I go to...
YouTube.com And I go to...
I go to...
The...
Custom...
How do I go?
Oh.
Earn.
I go to memberships.
I go to levels.
No, not levels.
I go to...
Customize perks.
One year.
Save.
Oh my god!
Is there anybody?
Oh my gosh.
Refresh the page.
I'm gonna refresh my page.
Oh my gosh, is there anyone here?
Anyone here in chat?
Any?
No.
Wait, you're my bot.
You do not count.
Phantom-san, do you speak Japanese?
Do you speak Japanese?
I can speak a little.
A little.
I see you.
I see you!
Thank you!
Wait, where are you?
Fake day!
Everything is loading so slowly for some reason.
Thank you.
Yay!
It's so small.
No, it's perfect.
Yay!
Who upjorked in there once?
You're doing that!
Should I add that on the badge?
Let's see.
Here, hold on.
Straight...
Jorkin...
One.
Straight jorkin one.
Till I'm dead!
Yeah!
We should fill in some space here.
What should we put here?
Wow!
VHD!
Let's go!
Add snake there?
I'm using tiny snake as a reference.
The rise of the old wisp.
Let's see.
That's his beard.
Side patch.
His bandana.
His tuft of hair.
His actual hair.
Wait, no!
Hold on, hold on, hold on.
Maybe not straight jorkin.
I know what to do.
I know what to put instead.
I know.
Struck with inspiration just now.
You become the jorker.
We live in a society.
I already took a screenshot of me with...
No!
No, the other one, no!
This is the real one!
That's life, that's life.
Something, something, something.
Sometimes you're dead, sometimes you're straight jorkin it.
But I'm gonna be the number one jorker.
It's gonna be me.
That's afterlife.
The jorker is crazy.
Yeah, the jorker.
And then here, you know what this is?
Society.
We don't live in it because we're dead!
We don't live in a society.
We're dead in a society.
Who loves jorking their snake while they're whispering?
Straight up becoming the jorker.
Okay, now I save this.
Okay, now I change it.
I go back.
Replace image.
Alright, save and publish.
Alright, our masterpiece.
You guys, this is just temporary.
This is just temporary.
I wanna get ones for the other months too, so...
So don't worry.
Why is it hashed after number one?
Because I wrote one first and then I didn't have enough room.
Snake jorker?
No, that's snake beater.
I want it to stay.
We'll get to one year and then we'll re-decide, okay?
We'll re-think about it.
You guys probably won't even remember.
You guys are probably gonna be like, what was this again?
Well guys, I...
I think I'm gonna end it here.
It's a bit of a shorter stream.
But I am so sleepy after...
After...
Phantom No Nazo.
But I'm glad we could play both games.
I'm still... I'm so shocked that this game was so difficult.
That it was actually so much like the original.
I'm so shocked.
Takezo, thanks for the 500.
Kevin, thanks for the super chat.
Tomorrow might be a bit longer.
Tomorrow and Saturday might be a bit longer stream, so...
I think it's harder than Atlantis No Nazo.
Truly, Gibby did his homework.
Yeah.
Game was really well done.
It really was.
Like...
In terms of being a...
A replica of the original.
Yeah.
Oyasuminasai.
Maomao, thanks for the 5 gifted.
Yeah, so tomorrow...
I think we decided for...
The collab on Sunday, I can say, I think...
Is going to be the Sloppy Sisters again.
I invited them to play Buckshot Roulette with me.
So, oh my gosh, Liars Bar and Buckshot Roulette in the same week.
Oh, Snuffy mentioned it yesterday.
Yeah, so...
The four of us will be playing that.
I really want to play...
Limu, I found out she really likes Lethal Company.
And I always want to play more Lethal Company.
For those who are part of the...
Oh wait, hold on.
Hold on.
Let me double check when I'm doing that.
Yeah, for those who are part of the...
Who were, I guess...
The...
The Patreon.
Next week, I'll have a stream.
Wait, what time am I streaming tomorrow?
Oh, kind of early.
I gotta record some stuff.
I have to record some stuff.
And then...
From next month, probably.
Because Matara will be coming next week.
So next week is a little busy with her.
And then the week after is December.
So starting next month...
There will be more membership streams.
If you're just like, Man, Minto doesn't really do many membership streams.
The reason I haven't done so many is because...
I...
Besides because we had the podcast in the beginning...
Is because I've been out of town so often...
That I'm always just wanting to stream on my main channel...
To show that I'm actually...
I'm like, YouTube couldn't look at me.
I'm actually making content.
Please, don't kick me out of the algorithm.
So I'm like...
It's hard to like...
It was hard to balance when I could do membership.
And I also...
Don't like doing them on days where...
Like on weekdays.
And I have had my weekends filled with so much stuff.
So...
But I think...
When things like that happen, I think I'm just gonna try and...
Get two streams in one day.
I think it might be easier to do.
Get me out of the algorithm!
My brain is not braining.
How's there some one-year memberships already within seven months?
By the way, I got a name suggestion for you and Doki.
The Sloppy Bandits.
It's like the Sticky Bandits from Home Alone 2, but sloppy.
I like it.
And the reason there's some one-year members...
Is because they were members...
Way back...
In 2020.
When I had memberships open...
Initially.
And so...
It kind of just carried over the months.
It carried over the months...
From when they were...
When they were members back when I originally streamed.
The OGs.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I never realized that it carried over.
Yeah, before I went to heaven.
So...
Honestly, I want to make something...
So awesome for you guys.
For that, because I can't believe you guys are even still here.
You guys are even still watching me.
That's insane.
I never left.
Yeah, you've been here a while too, Jeremy.
Craziness.
How did yesterday's meeting go?
Oh, it was so great!
Yeah, thanks for asking.
I can't tell you anything about it though.
But you'll know...
Not too long from now actually, I think.
Actually...
No.
I can't say.
Meeting went good.
You'll never be rid of us.
Oh, look, Lilybreeze.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Look who's streaming.
Look who's not gone!
Tell us something, we are dying here.
No.
Is Mitara still coming over for Thanksgiving?
She is, yeah.
We plan on streaming at least once...
Together.
Yeah, yeah.
It's kind of difficult because...
My mom wants to go out...
For Thanksgiving.
Do stuff, so...
But I will...
Obviously let you guys know when that is.
Poker Night!
Welcome to Bamboo Ship Vacuum!
I'm here since your debut, silly ghostman.
I know!
So wait, since my debut?
You?
Why?
So cool to see how folks keep raising the bar of famworks.
Truly you're a great muse.
Thanks, Tom!
Thank you for the spooky dodo, Aichi!
I want to say I visited a lot of places from your Akiba Mid Tour a few months ago...
And had a lot of fun.
To your stage in Akiba Zettai Ryuki were two of my favorites that I frequented.
I have many tickets now.
Can you leak your recipe for sweet potato casserole?
I'm in charge of some dishes this Thanksgiving.
I was going to try making it.
It's my mom's recipe.
I can ask her.
I'll ask her, Nana.
I don't think it's anything so special though.
I don't think it's so special.
But I told my mom she has to make it because Matara asked about it.
But Matara was just like, I don't really like sweet stuff.
My mom puts marshmallows in it, so...
I don't know.
Did I miss the game?
Sorry, Nipples.
You missed the whole stream.
I'm ending!
Thank you guys for hanging out with me tonight!
I will see you when I see you next.
Get some water and have a good night.
Have a good day.
Get some rest.
We're almost to the weekend.
The weekend's in like two days.
Otamito!
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Bye bye!
Do you guys want to help me make a video real quick?
Let's make a video together that I'm going to post online.
Actually, it might take more than a minute.
You know what?
I'll just catch you guys later.
You'll see it when I post it.
Fakeny, thanks for the superchat!
Okay.
Bye bye!
Sorry for the bait and switch.
Sorry, sorry.
I'll see you.
You'll see it.
It's probably not even that...
But...
Don't worry about it.
Don't worry.
This is a dumb idea.
I came up with it this morning.
I was like, I'm going to make this into a video.
I'm going to...
I'm going to post it online!